there's no doubt that the Multiverse
Saga is about to get really really
exciting especially with the true
introduction of Kang the Conqueror
coming in Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and no doubt that it will
end with a bang the Multiverse is about
to be blown wide open we're about to see
a bunch of different characters coming
from other different universes and
there's even the huge possibility that
some of the characters that are no
longer around that we know and love like
Tony Stark and black widow could
possibly be returning as variants in
Avengers Secret Wars so everything is
set up for the next two phases to be
extremely huge however it looks like
there are going to be a few more things
set up in the Multiverse Saga that are
going to be big not only for this Saga
but also the next one as well and we are
specifically talking about the Fantastic
Four the Silver Surfer and Galactus all
of which seem to be coming in not just
phase six but possibly some in Phase
five as well so today we're going to be
going over reports about about the
Fantastic forecasting specifically about
Reed Richards aka Mr fantastic news
about the Silver Surfer project and when
it will come and what and who it will
set up and of course the who we all know
is going to be Galactus and when
Galactus is coming and how long Galactus
is going to stick around for and how it
will all tie in to Avengers Secret Wars
now originally with how everything is
set up in the Multiverse Saga we thought
that we would have to wait a pretty long
time to see the Silver Surfer and
Galactus show up in the MCU probably
after Secret Wars however recently there
have been a lot of reports that state
the Silver Surfer is going to be coming
to the MCU sooner rather than later the
cosmic circus has reported that the
Silver Surfer project is going to be a
Disney plus special and although at this
point in time it looks like Marvel
Studios hasn't really decided what they
want whether that's the Silver Surfer
project to be an actual movie or to be a
Disney plus special they have decided
that the Silver Surfer is going going to
be coming also side note we've kind of
heard the same rumors about Nova we know
a Nova project is coming but it looks
like Marvel Studios haven't decided
whether they want that to be a Disney
plus special a Disney Plus show or a
movie but some reports about the Silver
Surfer project state that he is actually
coming before the Fantastic Four movie
now since the Fantastic Four film pretty
much starts off phase six then we could
probably expect the Silver Surfer movie
to come in Phase 5. now I know Phase 5
has already been completely scheduled
out and we have the release dates for
all of the projects but keep in mind
these special presentations don't ever
really have slots on the phase slates
when they released the Slate for phase 4
werewolf by Knight wasn't on there yet
we got werewolf By Night neither was the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
so just because Marvel has not revealed
a Silver Surfer project for Phase 5 does
not mean that it won't come in phase 5.
and the good news about this is that it
seems like the Fantastic Four is going
to be a much bigger movie than any of us
thought this is what The Insider film
Odyssey had to say way back in October
of last year Silver Surfer being a
special presentation and releasing
before the Fantastic Four film is a huge
indicator that the Fantastic Four movie
is going to be massive I had heard of a
Silver Surfer project in the works I
believe I've spoken about it before but
I assumed it was a long way away this is
amazing now he also goes on to talk
about Galactus and when he's coming but
let's first talk about Fantastic Four
this movie is Kevin feiges who is the
president of Marvel Studios for those
who may not know baby it's his baby it's
his favorite and it's something that he
has anticipated and been working on for
a very long time Marvel's first family
the Fantastic Four we know that Kevin
feige is going to put so much into this
film that it has to be amazing and of
course two big parts of that are the
cast and the story and if these reports
are true Kevin feige really is going all
out having the Silver Surfer be
introduced before the movie so they can
address the silver Surfer and have him
in the actual film now as far as casting
goes we haven't really heard anything
about the Silver Surfer there have been
names thrown out there that fans think
could be good like Keanu Reeves who I do
actually think could make a very very
great Silver Surfer just think of his
voice as nor and Rad plus we can assume
that the Silver Surfer will be around
for a pretty long time which means Keanu
Reeves could possibly be around in the
MCU for a pretty long time but nothing
official at all yet for the Silver
Surfer however we've had many reports
about The Fantastic Four now
unfortunately it really is looking like
John Krasinski will not be playing the
main Reed Richard slash Mr Fantastic of
the MCU sadly it's looking like that
could have just been a one-time thing
for Multiverse of Madness maybe a
two-time thing because he'll probably
show up in secret Wars Kevin feige did
admit that he did that simply to kind of
please the fans but since the Fantastic
Four film is his baby he's not really
gonna do anything for fan service he's
going to do what he thinks is Right
which means Jon is probably not playing
Mr Fantastic in the MCU not our main one
at least and film ought to see that same
account even said this back in December
as well just stumbled across a section
of Twitter in which people only want
John Krasinski as Reed Richards and hate
anyone who says he isn't going to be
Reed Richards I fear they might hate
Marvel soon heavily implying that John
Krasinski will not be Mr Fantastic
however the reports that we have heard
state that one of two people might be
pretty likely to play Mr Fantastic or at
least are in the running for him right
now many people have reported this but I
think the first report Came From Grace
Randolph where she stated that a Star
Wars actor is in the running to play Mr
Fantastic and based off of everything
that we've heard so far the actor that
could be playing Mr Fantastic coming
over from Star Wars could be either Adam
Driver who of course played kylo Ren or
Diego Luna Andor now I'm genuinely
curious to hear what fans think of both
of these actors possibly playing Reed
Richards so let us know right now in the
comments down below do you like one of
them both of them neither of them let us
know now since both actors are already
pretty tight with Disney it's pretty
easy for them to jump right over to
Marvel and these actors have probably
ran into Kevin foggy at one point in
time and they're probably on his radar
for anything Kevin feige says he meets
with a lot of different actors to
possibly see if anything's there for
them to play in the MCU just to see so
one of these two could very well go on
to be our main Mr Fantastic of the MCU
so one of these two could be taking on
the Silver Surfer but also Galactus as I
mentioned film Odyssey also spoke about
Galactus when speaking about the Silver
Surfer being a special presentation they
also said this also lines up with
something else I heard about Galactus
being introduced before the Multiverse
Saga ends now this one I want to clarify
about because a lot of people have
actually asked me about this I don't
think Galactus is going to be a huge
character in Avengers Secret group Wars
could he appear yes but I think this is
probably more of a setup for phase 7 8
and 9 the next Saga Galactus might not
be the big bad of the next Saga he may
just be a huge big bad for the Fantastic
Four after all the Fantastic Four and of
course the Silver Surfer have a super
long history with Galactus and a great
history so it would make sense that the
Silver Surfer would come before the
Fantastic Four movie but the Fantastic
Four film itself would address the
threat of Galactus now what I think
could probably happen is the Fantastic
Four run into the Silver Surfer in their
film and they learn about Galactus and
we probably see some type of a flashback
or a cut scene of what the Silver Surfer
has dealt with before Galactus being his
Herald this could give us the threat
that Galactus is indeed coming then
after Avengers Secret Wars when they
finally defeat Kang I can imagine
something going on like this some
Avengers speaking with the Fantastic
Four saying well I'm glad the threat is
finally done I'm glad we've saved not
only our universe but but the Multiverse
as well but then the Fantastic Four come
out and say well we're not done yet and
that starts the new saga and sets up
Galactus to come in Phase seven now of
course there is always the possibility
that Galactus could be a character an
Avenger Secret Wars heck he could even
be on Kang side Kang could be
controlling him somehow and using him as
a weapon to destroy universes however if
they do plan on Galactus being a pretty
big character after phase six they
probably don't want to utilize him too
much during phase five or six that way
he really is a big deal when he finally
comes in the next Saga but either way
the Fantastic Four is seemingly going to
be a very huge movie Silver Surfer is
apparently coming before them and we are
apparently getting Galactus in phase six
of the MCU before we get him later on in
the next Saga so this is super exciting
but hey go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below and let us know what
you hope to see for all of these
characters don't forget to like this
video And subscribe you don't miss out
on any of the latest Marvel news or live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf